okay so it's been a couple weeks uh we
are back with Marvel's secret Invasion
event yes and those are the guys who are
asking we will make a full story video
at the end of this whole thing right
we'll probably release it in time for
the main secret Invasion show that comes
out but the thing about this is kind of
continuing this on right this sort of
shows us or or covers the continuing
invasion of the Scrolls against earth
now one of the cool things about this is
we're gonna get this Revelation that may
or may not be true and I'm curious to
see which one you guys believe but I'm
curious to see how you guys feel about
this but what this does is it picks up
after the collapse of the shield
Helicarrier right remember that was one
of the the strikes that was launched by
the Scrolls they launched a
multi-faceted strike against Earth that
initially they launched a strike against
the superheroes by literally just crash
landing a vessel into the Savage land
and when the various superheroes had
responded to it that you ended up having
them met by their former counterparts
right and we just didn't know which one
was which right was the Spider-Man who
had shown up in this Savage land what
he's the real Spiderman or was it the
one that came out of the ship we didn't
really know exactly what was going on
and that was part of the confusion that
the Scrolls were creating is throwing
out doppelgangers and then forcing the
superheroes on Earth to actually
question whether or not they were
Scrolls and then to question their
teammates right just kind of sowing
doubt the other part of this was them
launching a traditional attack in the
city of New York as well as other places
around the world in addition to taking
down Shield their technology as well as
Stark Tech right so basically blinding
all forms of Intelligence on Earth so
nobody really knows what's going on
right so when you end up having Maria
Hill who again is the current director
of shield in Marvel Comics at least at
the time this story is being written
when she takes off to the surface of the
Helicarrier she's met by Jarvis now
Jarvis is historically The Avengers
Butler the fact that he's here and the
fact that the attack was launched of
course putting two and two together
Jarvis is a scroll which we already knew
for the most part right he was the one
that helped to orchestrate the attack
that took down shield and Stark Tech at
the same time but the fact that Jarvis
is an inside man for the Scrolls is a
big deal because the Avengers are pretty
knowledgeable about how shield works the
fact that Jarvis is a bad guy here means
he's basically able to bring down the
Avengers right which is a pretty
significant moment the other part of
this is we basically switch over to Camp
Hammond now this requires a bit of
explanation for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar with Marvel
Comics Camp Hammond is one and really
kind of the main site of the initiative
so the way this worked in Marvel Comics
is that as most of you guys know you had
Civil War and again we've talked about
this before so for those of you guys who
are familiar with this bear with me here
for a second when it came to Civil Wars
most of you guys know it was all fought
over superhero registration right that
if you were a person out there that had
superpowers whether you intended to use
them or not you had to register your
name your address the whole nine yards
with the federal government those
individuals who didn't want to sided
with Captain America those individuals
who did sided with Iron Man and this led
to a giant Rift in the superhero
Community ultimate admittedly Iron Man
Reed Richards Hank Pym Ant-Man those
guys who were on the side of
registration they effectively won and
what they ended up doing was
implementing the 50-state initiative
which was literally a
government-sanctioned superhero team in
all 50 states in terms of planning it
was pretty great right it was pretty
awesome and the reality is I always
sided with registration because what
that does is it basically holds people
accountable whereas people like Captain
America didn't want to be held
accountable for the things they did
right otherwise they would have been on
the side of registration and so what
this means is that it kept Hammond you
have a kind of coming together of what
is in effect the most capable members of
the 50 state initiative not everybody
from the initiative is here is basically
like the top of the class right like
those individuals who are like in the
one percent of the class they get
straight A's for lack of a better
analogy here but they're basically
gathered because no one knows exactly
what's going on or at least they're not
being made aware of what's going on now
eventually they're told by some of the
individuals like Diamondback who kind of
run the Initiative Program in the apps
of Hank Pam and those guys and
essentially saying like they don't know
where the Avengers are Communications
with shield and Iron Man and all that
stuff is down right like nobody knows
how to get anybody they're literally
Flying Blind but then him basically
shows up out of nowhere and tells them
like there's an attack in the city of
New York this is what you've been
training for we have to go respond now
that's one of the things to understand
the idea behind the initiative and it
was an actual comic book line it wasn't
very good but it was an actual comic
book line uh the idea was to literally
train them and get them prepared so they
could actually be superheroes that could
help alongside the Avengers but that's
all they would really be for the most
part I mean the ones who were like the
absolute best they would go on and join
the Avengers proper but for the most
part The Avengers Initiative Program was
kind of like if we need help we will
call you right until you've proved that
you're a person that can actually stand
on the battlefield in a meaningful
capacity the reality here though is that
this is kind of an all hands on deck
situation and so where you have all
these Scrolls who would invaded the city
of New York and they're all basically
using some variation of a combination of
superhero powers or just direct
duplicates of superheroes Wolverine Iron
Man different things like that that you
do have like Vision who's here you also
have the Young Avengers right now here's
the kind of caveat here because you're
going to notice Wiccan around here when
it comes to Wiccan those of you guys who
aren't familiar with him Wiccan is
ridiculously powerful right like as the
son of the Scarlet Witch arguably he's
more powerful than she is depending on
what era of comics you're reading and
where his powers are he is destined to
become the uh the demiurge basically
meaning he's going to be the most
powerful being on Earth and quite
literally one of the most powerful
beings in the universe he hasn't quite
reached that point yet because he
doesn't have fine-tuned control of his
abilities on that scale but this is one
of those moments where basically Brian
Michael bendus invokes a character
that's stupidly powerful but you never
actually see him use the full totality
of his abilities it's just kind of the
way Brian Michael Bendis writes he's
very consistent with his writing style
but at the end of the day of course you
have hulkling who initially responds now
hogling is half scroll he's not a Hulk
right despite his name I know you're
like my initial thought when they first
introduced hulking when I first got into
him was like okay we don't know his
entire basis is he like the son of the
Hulk or something like that no he's just
had scroll but he is a shape shifter and
he is a cool character but the thing
about this is because he's half scroll
he initially tries to play Diplomat
right like hey guys I'm half scroll is
cool you guys got to stop you can't do
this but one of the things to remember
is the scroll Empire as it exists now it
really takes place in the aftermath of
Galactus destroying pretty much their
entire home world as well as a whole
host of the Scrolls being obliterated
themselves during the annihilation event
so all you really have left of the
scroll Empire is basically just a
religiously guided race which is being
led by their Queen for the most part and
so because of that they're really here
with religious fanaticism right like we
are destined to take this place this is
like our Manifest Destiny essentially
and they're looking to conquer it right
like that's that's kind of what their
goal is here and as a result of that
there's no way to really bargain with
them right I mean when you have an
individual who is Guided by religious
zealotry whatever the religious figure
is that's the only person they're going
to listen to and so in the absence of
that religious figure they will believe
the person that they identify with the
most who claims to speak on behalf of
that religious figure in times of
desperation people will believe what
they want to believe and in the instance
of this it's the Scrolls believing that
their their end is nigh when a religious
figure pops up in the case of the queen
and saying I can lead us to greener
pastures they will follow her with
unwavering loyalty and that's exactly
what's happening here that's why you
can't bargain with them that's why you
can't talk them down because they
believe it's their mission from their
gods to conquer Earth and so where you
do have the initiative that steps in and
does what they can for the most part
they're a stopgap measure it's sticking
a piece of bubble gum on a a leak in a
wall right it's going to hold for a
little bit but they're not going to save
the day and so what this does is it
switches over to the Savage land with
basically Jessica Drew Spider Woman now
previously we had talked about how the
queen was impersonating somebody she was
going forward to claim to be someone in
the secret Invasion event this is it
right she claims to be Spider-Woman
right like she literally took on the
form of Spider Woman now here's the
thing to understand there's more that
goes on here than simply the Scrolls
just taking on the form of a person they
have a whole process and it's really
really cool it's pretty badass but of
course when she shows up here she
immediately takes out Echo now of course
a lot of you guys may know Echo from the
Hawkeye TV series she he's been around
in Marvel Comics for a little while she
was never important no one ever really
cared about her she was just there
occasionally and did some stuff and was
interesting sometimes I guess it wasn't
until Marvel decided they were gonna put
her in the Hawkeye show that in the
comics they started to elevate her they
gave her the Phoenix force and all that
kind of stuff here's the funny thing
people still don't care so I mean she's
not an interesting character and she
never was
she's not cool because she's basically
task master right like she can copy the
fighting styles of other people been
there done that right I mean that's
literally all it is when it comes to her
character so that's why people never
really cared about her too much but the
thing about this is Jessica Drew takes
out Echo immediately like right off the
bat incapacitates her now there is a
reason why the queen chose Spider-Woman
above everybody else and we'll cover
that when we go into like the
transformation process when the Scrolls
take on the form of somebody else
because there is a huge motivation and
it's really really cool but what she
ends up doing is basically traveling to
see Tony Stark now one of the things to
know is that when the secret Invasion
event first kicked off and like
technology really like start taking
everything went offline what it also
meant is that Tony Stark's suit was not
really capable of keeping his body safe
the way that it previously had he's
literally dying right that's literally
what's happening his fever is like 102
his body's basically shutting down and
so he's trying to find a way to get his
suit back up and running again now the
thing about this is when Jessica shows
up he's kind of like look no offense
girl but like I don't really want to
talk to anybody I have to focus on
trying to find a way to fix this suit
now under any normal circumstance Tony
Stark would do this in an instant right
this suit would be sorted out quick fast
and in a hurry but one of the things to
remember is that they're in the Savage
land right and we talked about this in a
previous video The Savage land is out
there in Antarctica somewhere sure it's
been a place that's been explored and
used by multiple people over the years
Mr Sinister Magneto right like hazar who
nobody cares about he's basically
Marvel's Tarzan but like it's been used
by a lot of different people but the
technology is archaic right so this is
basically Tony Stark trying to fix his
suit in a cave with a box of scraps
that's literally what this is right he
can only do so much with the archaic
technology that's available here but the
funny thing is that when Jessica shows
up when the queen shows up here she
actually starts screwing with the mind
of Tony Stark right what she says is
like your work on Earth is done right
thank you Tony Stark for everything that
you've accomplished here and he's like
what in the world are you talking about
right her response is you will go down
and our people's history as the greatest
Soldier the Armada has ever had and you
will always and forever have my undying
love the love of your queen and where
she's trying to convince Tony Stark that
he's a scroll he refuses to believe that
it's true but here's one of the things
you remember this is him speaking and
it's really him just trying to convince
himself that's the kicker here right and
again we'll go more into this process in
a future video but when the Scrolls take
on the form of superheroes it's not just
copying them they believe they're that
person it's one of the things that Tony
Stark figured out right at the very
beginning of the story that we started
covering here it's one of the things
that Tony Stark realized when Electro
was revealed to be a scroll the reason
why her mind couldn't be read by
telepaths and they couldn't figure out
that she was a scroll the reason why she
didn't smell like a scroll to Wolverine
is because for all intents and purposes
and by all standards of measurement they
are or that person right they genuinely
believe that they are that person and so
when the queen comes along and uses that
information against Tony Stark it leads
Tony Stark down the path of doubting
himself perhaps I really am a scroll
which is why he's trying to basically
convince himself in saying this as
opposed to talking to her and it's kind
of the funny thing because she says like
you performed admirably Tony Stark none
of this would have been possible had it
not been for you right you initiated the
superhero Civil War you became director
of Shield you're the one that basically
ignored the entirety of the Scrolls
secretly replacing all of these
different superheroes on Earth had it
not been for you we never would have
been able to pull this off now this
conversation is ridiculously important
especially when it comes to the end of
secret Invasion and then you start going
into dark Reign which we may or may not
cover I don't know if we're gonna do
that or not it's a cool story arc it's
not really an event it's more of like a
branding initiative but I'll make sense
of it once we get closer to the end of
secret Invasion once we get to the end
of secret Invasion but the thing about
this is that it's a really really
important conversation here but in a lot
of ways she's using the history of Tony
Stark against him because he did
initiate the superhero Civil War and he
did become director of shield and it was
under his watch as director of Shield
that the Scrolls were secretly replacing
superheroes he was part of the
Illuminati the Illuminati were the ones
who went to the scrolled Homeworld in
the first place and set all this in
motion by telling the Scrolls never to
visit earth right remember when we
covered that one shot the Scrolls had
incapacitated the Illuminati and started
analyzing their DNA and came to the
realization we can copy their
superpowers right it's not simply us
just taking on their forms if we explore
this possibility long enough not only
can we copy the forms of superheroes on
Earth we can copy their powers and then
we can make it impossible for them to
detect the fact that we are Scrolls
right we can push this to its limit and
so jumping back to Manhattan back at
Times Square where this main event's
going on as you would expect the
initiative is getting absolutely wrecked
right and the crazy thing about this is
that this is all being recorded it's all
being broadcast live on TV so quite
literally the entirety of the earth is
watching as the superheroes in New York
who are really like the last stand right
they're the ones that are supposed to
keep the world protected they're getting
obliterated by the forces of the Scrolls
even vision is destroyed by the Scrolls
themselves because remember they've been
prepping for this war for quite some
time they've been studying the
superheroes long enough to know how to
overcome their various abilities so
destroying Vision destroying these other
members of the superhero Community all
basically seems lost but in the midst of
all of this everything around the
entirety of New York starts to shake
literally the whole city starts shaking
and what ends up happening is Nick Fury
and his Howling Commandos emerge with
Daisy Johnson leading the charge now
here's something that I want to
celebrate if I hear right and this it's
one of the things that I hated the most
about Agents of Shield Agents of Shield
was a cool show it was an interesting
show they de-powered Quake so bad it was
ridiculous Daisy Johnson in the comics
is stupidly powerful I mean she's one of
these characters where this it's
arguable that she's Omega Level because
she can literally create earthquakes to
the point that she could actually
shatter worlds it's not how overpowered
she is but in the show she was it was I
mean I get the MCU Dev Powers people
that's just the nature of things just
how the MCU works but she was so weak
compared to her comic book version and
that's gonna be nuts because while Nick
Fury's team is here and they they are
gonna put a dent in the Scrolls even
Daisy Johnson's power and her ability to
create earthquakes on virtually any
scale is not really going to be enough
to turn the tide with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later peace